My son has a rare autoimmune disorder, pyoderma, gangriosome.
He has been under care of a team of doctors in St. Louis University.
High-dose prednisone almost killed him.
They wanted him an immunosuppressant stop right there.
So yes, if a person has an autoimmune disease from a medical standpoint, especially if
they're an acute flare, they're going to put him on an anti-inflammatory immunosuppressant
because an autoimmune disease, when it's in its acute flare, is in a hyper-TH1 response.
So prednisone steroid is going to calm that down.
The problem is people can react apparently to steroids.
So in this case, it was a great reaction to prednisone that this person said almost killed
him.
They want him an immunosuppressant.
That would be the medical treatment for an autoimmune disease.
Try to suppress the immune system.
We do not want to go this route where we're using holistic plant-based treatments but need
more help.
It's terrifying.
It's only 37.
It needs his life back.
Thank you.
It advanced.
First of all, that's the medical route.
How to treat an autoimmune disease is to use immune suppressants.
It actually will, in many cases, decrease the person's symptoms.
The problem is it does nothing to address the problem.
So I'm going to highly recommend anybody with an autoimmune disease at this person if they're
listening to their question being answered, to go and join our chronic disease and autoimmune
course.
Because I go into great detail about what to do with an autoimmune disease.
First of all, an autoimmune disease when your body starts making antibodies against its
own tissue.
If you're starting to make antibodies against cells in the skin or the subcutaneous layer of
the skin, that's a type of autoimmune disease.
It's a type of autoimmune disease that is a pio-derma autoimmune disease.
So rare disease.
I had to look it up when I saw this question.
It creates boils and stuff on the skin and you can create antibodies to any tissue, any
tissue, any cell line in your body, and that's what an autoimmune disease is.
Why is it there?
So first of all, that's a good thing to look for.
Because the person has some sort of toxicity, heavy metal toxicity that cause the body
to end up creating antibodies against cell tissue many times when either a toxin or a biotoxin
is in the body and it goes intracellular inside the cell.
The immune system is going to fire to try to kill it, apparently if it's a toxin, because
it toxin can't die.
Normally, if it's a biotoxin, because that's what the immune system is supposed to do is kill
biotoxin.
But if it goes inside the cell, your immune system can't kill it.
And if it's firing at a TH1, TH2 response multiple times, the TH2 response is the B cell response
that then creates antibodies.
It's supposed to create antibodies against the infection, let's say strap or something like
that.
But if this thing keeps going inside the cell or if this toxin is inside the cell, an immune
system is apparently seeing a toxin as something that needs to kill, it can create antibodies
to that cell line where it's found.
So finding out what a cause of this is can be helpful because you can help detox that and
help calm that down.
More importantly, you have to find out what the person's triggers are.
So anything that will trigger an immune response is going to make the damage to whatever tissue
that that person has antibodies against, aka the type of autoimmune disease.
It's going to cause that to flare.
So a person says, I have this pyodermal autoimmune disease and it keeps flaring and it's so
bad, it's horrible.
You've got to find out what other triggers are stimulating the person's immune response.
Or you're just going to go a medical route, you're just going to do an immune suppressive.
That's just to mean that will help in an acute situation, but that's not the wrong term
way to treat an autoimmune disease.
You have to find out the cause, you have to find out what the triggers are.
There's ways to test for this and I go into exhausting detail on that course.
So if you don't test for and find out what your triggers are, you are just committed to
just having, you know, just constant flares of this disease and horrible life.
You can find out what those triggers are, you can calm those down wherever this is.
I've been patients with MS and antibodies to myelin cheese cells.
If you find out what your triggers are, you can calm down that immune response, then you
could work on some natural anti-inflammatory things.
And you could really help get that person's life back under control.
This person says, we are doing a holistic plant-based treatment.
Why would caution you highly that, you know, what are those holistic plant-based treatments?
If you're doing herbals that are stimulated in immune response, you're making the person
works.
So if you're doing any type of natural care with an autoimmune disease, that is stimulated
in immune response, you're making the person works.
Perfect example is person like, I have chronic Lyme, but it's really not chronic Lyme, it's
they have autoimmune disease now.
And that's what their symptoms are.
And they keep taking, you know, cat's claw or some immune stimulant.
Now I'm taking this.
Now I'm doing this a straggler's protocol for Lyme.
This is just absolutely the wrong thing to do.
You can't be doing immune stimulants when you have self-antibodies.
You know, I've said this a million times, once you have self-antibodies and you stimulate
the immune response from any source, you are going to kill.
That what you have antibodies against self, that means you're going to kill self tissue.
You're going to cause a flare.
So if you take vitamin C, it's immune stimulant, you're going to cause a flare.
You take garlic, it's immune stimulant, you're going to cause a flare.
You take a straggler's, you take echinacea, you're going to cause a flare.
Well, I'm trying to kill the bacteria or I'm trying to kill the Lyme, but try to kill this,
or my natural doctor said to do this.
A lot of doctors, whether they're natural or not natural doctors, don't understand
an autoimmune disease, so highly suggest you take that course.
We have doctors taking that course, 50 bucks, that will help.
You'll learn something.
But set up a case review with me if you want to through the course or through our website.